um and click on books the great mayor is
a new biography of former New York City
Mayor Fiorello LaGuardia now we go live
to New York City for author Alan Bronski
this is live coverage on book TV's fifth
anniversary weekend good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to Barnes & Noble this afternoon
were celebrating the fifth anniversary
of book TV with a special live
presentation of Ellen broadsky here to
discuss his new biography the great
mayor this is indeed a comprehensive
biography of Fiorello LaGuardia mayor of
New York who served and unprecedented
three four-year terms between 1933 and
1945 and won seven terms as congressman
born in varrock place in Greenwich
Village in 1882 LaGuardia followed his
musician father to military outposts in
the West brought up Episcopalian by
Italian Catholic and Jewish immigrant
parents in an effort to Americanize him
with chapters headed by LaGuardia notes
such as I want to be somebody and do
something really worthwhile Allen
chronicles the life of the diminutive
scrapper who learned early on to
challenge authority especially and
causes that championed the rights of
laborers
he hated professional politicians in
accessible prose and telling photographs
Allen creates a stunning portrait of an
unforgettable mayor who claimed they
didn't elect me for my looks
Allen Brodsky is the author of several
biographies including one on Grover
Cleveland and was editorial director of
two multi volume encyclopedias he has
lectured on history and classical music
and served as a combat correspondent and
feature writer for Pacific stars and
stripes he's been a book critic and
columnist for US newspapers ladies and
gentlemen please welcome Ellen
broadsky and the great mayor I'll start
by saying two things first of all I'm
not gonna give a formal oration because
I detest them and I wouldn't reflect
them on anybody because I want to listen
one myself the important thing is and
this is what I want to stress is that
all Americans living west of 10th Avenue
should not consider this a
New York book it's basic it is the story
of how this man created modern New York
City he took five mutually and pathetic
semi-autonomous disparate counties
incidentally the boroughs of New York
City are also the counties of New York
State and he brought them all together
in one unified city but he was also a
mayor for all of the cities nowhere in
the Constitution are and is there any
provisions made for the cities the word
is not even mentioned
therefore the cities became the wards of
the states and when LaGuardia came in he
said the cities are the wards of the
federal government and it was because of
him that the federal government financed
through grants and loans the billions of
dollars that carried them through the
depression he was a great believer in a
great advocate of the rights of the
disenfranchised that politically
socially and economically
disenfranchised he hated politicians
which is true but he was one of the best
politicians around he hated political
organizations he ran one of the best
political organizations in the country
as he liked to say I can out demagogue
the best of the demagogues the thing is
that his political organization and who
was made up of his constituency his
consistency was the so-called hyphenates
Jewish American Italian American German
American Irish American those were his
constituencies he hated the interest the
so-called
what he called the interest the
oligarchs the the the bankers and the
the when he was this started when he was
a kid on the western frontier where he
was raised where his parents when he saw
that the American Indians as they were
known as a time we used a term Native
American
were being abused not only by the white
settlers but by the federal government
they were being cheated by the Bureau of
Indian Affairs and he never got over
that and it was the beginning of his
hatred for authority it was the
beginning of his insistence that
everybody should be treated equally when
he went to Congress and how he got to be
congressman is a miracle because he was
a Republican in a democratic controlled
area he represented the Greenwich
Village he got to be congressman because
he pushed his way in and when he was in
Congress he looked out for all of the
people his constituency was not the not
only his district which was made up of
the Italian Americans and the Jewish
Americans these were his two big
consistent constituencies he considered
the the entire nation his constituency
when there were trouble in the mind
fields of Kentucky and Pennsylvania and
you have to realize that it was against
the law to strike to picket any of that
the Pennsylvania and Kentucky
congressman didn't go running out there
the New York congressman went running
out there and he burrowed in and out of
every tunnel and he spoke to everybody
and he said when I get back to Congress
asbestos will not contain the report I'm
gonna give he when he was in Congress he
fought for the rights of all people he
was against the idea that the
immigration should be limited to the
so-called Nordics he he believed that
the immigration should be open to
everybody on an equal basis he believed
in equal taxation he became such a thorn
in the side of President Hoover that
President Hoover had to remove his
secretary of the Treasury who was
pushing for this economics that we now
know is reaganomics he had to get him
out of the country and sent him to
England is ambassador because LaGuardia
was going to have him brought to trial
he LaGuardia insisted that that he would
there be equal taxation he was he was he
was against so many of the obviously
thing worth being against prohibition
for one thing he was against prohibition
for three reasons for three rasa logical
reasons first of all you cannot
legislate morality the people that are
pushing for this abortion are
anti-abortion amendment they don't
realize that you cannot legislate
morality secondly he said look it's
going to cost us more money to try to
enforce prohibition than we would make
if we allow them to bring in the liquor
and pay the taxes and thirdly he said
the fact that you're telling the people
that they can't have whiskey or beer
they're gonna go out and get more and
it's only gonna lead to crime and it led
of course to the you know the Albie
Capone's in that that his concern with
people goes back to his period when he
was a acting consul in few me and
Trieste few of me was the port city of
Trieste which was the only outlet on the
Atlantic Ocean of the austro-hungarian
Empire which was really a geopolitical
abortion and everybody who wanted to get
through to emigrate to America where
they thought the streets were loaded
with gold had a pass to fiume now when
America when the immigrants came to the
country and landed in Ellis Island if
they had one of two diseases one was a
head disease and one was an eye disease
they were sent back they were sent back
on the next boat if a little boy of five
years old came with his family of nine
the family the eight members could stay
and a little boy had to go back or the
family had to go back and of course the
whole family couldn't go back they had
nothing to go back to they had sold
everything and they had come over here
it with their cardboard suitcases
he said look he said from that one we're
not going to allow them to leave the
port he said this is absolute cruelty
and he decided what on his own he went
down to the Cunard Line which ran a
transatlantic shuttle service and he
told the captain one day he said I have
my doctor here and he's going to examine
everybody on this ship not only the
emigrants but the passengers the crew
and you the captain examine them for
what he says he's been examined and if
he finds any case of this head or eye
disease they're not going to be able to
sail because we don't want them to be
turned back the captain said that's
ridiculous LaGuardia said well then you
don't get the permit to sail and without
a permit a ship cannot leave enter New
York Harbor so the cat's off all right
so the doctor did his examination and
after did the examination LaGuardia
presented the captain with the bill for
the doctor services so on the payment
I'm not paying that
look why I said okay he gave me
permission to sail the next ship that
came through three days later he put the
captain and the ship through the same
thing
he not only presented that bill but he
presented the bill that the other
captain hadn't paid and they had to pay
it and that was the beginning of the
idea of stopping the disease of the
source instead of these people being
turned back another stunt he pulled and
it was typical of his concern for the
people
sailing day was a big event in fiha
entry as if you may that was a day that
all the aristocrats would have capti
with the captain on the top deck and
then they would peer over and giggle as
the immigrants were being herded into
the ship he had heard that the one of
the arch tuck the favorite Archduchess
niece of the Emperor of Austria was
going to be in town for the day and
wanted to see a sailing and the sailing
the next gadget sailing was not
scheduled for three days they said no no
no no he said I'm not gonna put these
people these
getting people into a fetid dirty hold
for three days is to peel her to piece
her they said when we assist he said
look she runs her people I run my people
well they had a fit the cat the
governor-general of the province and the
port captain and the Cunard official
came and pleaded with him he said
absolutely not they said well let's have
an a sort of a show sail he will embark
a hundred people he said not one and he
said where to the cat and he said if you
embark one person before Saturday you're
not getting a permit well of course
Cunard couldn't do anything
meanwhile the Archduchess is having a
hemorrhage because he not only would not
let her see a sailing he turned down her
invitation of tea so the cat the port
captain sends out his Indian runners all
over town fine LaGuardia there went up
and down every alley and they went into
every movie house every pool parlor
every coffee huh
wherever LaGuardia was known to hang out
with with his with his compadres no sign
of him he had disappeared from the face
of the earth
and finally the Archduchess topped off
the ship and said well that's that we're
gonna make a present representation in
the federal government well the United
States government said look he was
within his rights oh don't bother us
meanwhile that night at a dinner party
beginning by the British ambassador
LaGuardia materializes like like the
Messiah they said where have you been
all day we thought you disappeared from
the face of the earth the the port
captain had people running all over the
place looking for you he said oh I had a
wonderful afternoon I had tea and lunch
with very dear friend of mine and she's
a very accomplished pianist LaGuardia
incidentally with a great terrific
musician and we had a wonderful
afternoon his hostess was the port
captain's wife and the afternoon was
held at his house so talk about hiding
in public when he came back to the
States
his mother said you know don't don't go
home stay
here and and be like a they have a nice
career in the State Department said no I
want to do something I want to be
something I want to amount to something
I want to do something for the people he
wanted to get into politics the only way
the best dad knew he suffer getting into
politics was through law well he didn't
even have a high school degree so he
went to a couple of people he said can
you help me get into law school they
said well we'll give you some courses
and if you can pass the courses we'll
grade you into law school well he got
into law school he was a dreadful
student I mean not only would he have
not been elected to the Edit the law
journal they wouldn't even let him on as
a copy boy but he managed to get through
law school and his only concern was for
the hyphenates the poor people these
were the disenfranchised people
politically economically and socially he
had two great constituencies the Jewish
Americans and the Italian Americans the
Irish Americans he wasn't interested in
because that was Tammany Hall
that was their sandbox and he said I
became a Republican because I hated
Tammany Hall Tammany Hall was to all
attendees the Democratic Party in New
York City he had a knack for languages
and he could address the people in any
number of language he spoke German
he spoke Croatian he's broke Hungarian
English and the most marvelous thing is
he was perfectly fluent in Yiddish and
one of his opponents in one of his
campaigns was a wretched wretched human
being who happened to be Jewish and he
challenged LaGuardia he said I'm insist
on a debate well look what he wasn't
afraid of him he couldn't care less look
what he said I'll debate him but the
debate has to be in Yiddish and the guy
was humiliated because he didn't know he
didn't even know what the word Oh he's
developed the Holtman
and that was the end of his career
when he was what he decided that he
wanted to be a congressman they said
forget about it the Republicans are not
elected from this district he said well
I'm gonna do it
he said well good luck you're not gonna
get anyplace his first campaign was an
utter mess he had no organization he was
a he learned from experience and he
organized a put together a political
part a political organization and the
most marvelous aspect of that
organization were these so-called jabo
knees now Chobani is the Italian word
for ape or Gibbons and these were these
young disenfranchised Italian Americans
who supported they like his Praetorian
Guard and the opposition said look at
them they're a bunch of apes well they
took it turned it around as a compliment
were he believed in in in fighting fire
with fire if he were making a speech on
a street corner and the opposition came
by started throwing apples and tomatoes
the Chobani would go up on the roof and
they will maybe carriages they would
break up the chimney they would do
anything his second hit second run for
mayor he learned his lesson he bought an
automobile for about two hundred dollars
got a bullhorn and he went up and down
every street on every street corner he
was calling attention if he saw the
opposition were having a street rally
then he would call them over and he
would start history to rally if he saw
three women talking discussing the price
of asparagus on the coin he would jump
right in and the next thing you knew it
was if it was a political discussion and
he had drawn 50 people because he
although he had a full set of voice that
at times when he was hysterical only the
bats indoors could hear it he can
attract people he ran up and down every
single tenement in his district he
knocked on every door he entered as they
were all poor they entered he introduced
himself he went to every confirmation he
went to every Bar Mitzvah he
went to every wedding he was he were
wherever anything was going on he was
there talking it up now he did not hate
aristocrats he just hated the old guards
because believe it or not it was the
aristocrats who made him mayor these
were the predominantly German Jewish and
some not Jewish bankers and but
reformers there were the formers there
were four reformers Democrats and the
Reformed Republicans the same sort of
group that I'd like to Grover Cleveland
president
they made him they created the fusion
because the Republicans in one he part
of him it was an embarrassment they said
you can't control this guy see the
Republicans had a deal with the
Democrats will let you have New York
State then we'll take New York City this
was the Democrats so the Republicans had
the state and the Democrats had the city
until Al Smith who would believe it or
not was a Tammany man came along and got
himself elected governor and then then
that gentleman's agreement ought and
anyway he got elected to Congress he
became a chief nudnik in Congress he was
a progressive was a progressive in them
in the mold of Norris senator Norris and
the senator wheeler and Robert La
Follette and there were one or two
Republicans who were also in that mold
but he said I'm doomed to be in the
minority party although he was in the
minority party you would think that he
was running the show he was sitting and
and make nasty remarks in Congress if
things weren't going his way he was a
very Manichean person it was either good
or bad you either good or evil and to
use the present-day location location
his story was it's either my way or the
highway
well his way was usually the right way
because he fought he fought for child
labor laws
he fed me he fought for labor period as
a matter of fact he was the co-author of
the norris-laguardia ACT which
constrained the Supreme Court of
Congress and the Supreme Court from
forbidding labor unions to organize and
picket
he was a great labor lawyer when he
started out as a lawyer he which he had
two floor firms one one was a Jewish
American law firm and the other was an
Italian American law firm and he was
charging like five dollars a dollar
whatever you could afford he was not in
it for the money when he left in the
second in his first term in Congress he
decided that he wanted to go to war now
he was a great believer in in flaw in it
in airpower he had taken air air
airplane flying lessons in the before
when war first broke out in Europe in
1915 he said I can't take this off but I
can fly it like a buzzard I mean his
takeoff and landings were always
adventures one almost killed him when
war broke out when we went to war in
April he pushed through a bill that
created an Air Force because the United
States had one warplane he decided that
he wanted to be made he wanted to be in
the air in the air in the air service it
was part it wasn't yet if core was part
of the United States to Simmons signal
court he went to were the chair the
House Speaker and he said who was there
Democrat as incidentally the famous sham
Clarke he said would you hold my seat if
I go to war sham Clarke said of course I
will they liked him they liked him
the Liberals liked him he said but
you're not gonna get your congressional
salary he said I'll worry about that
when I got back well to get ahead he got
the salary he got everything that was
coming to him he joined the they decided
to use him in the air arm at first he
didn't want it known that he was a
congressman
built the air force well that secret
lasted about five minutes because he
made sure everybody knew what he had to
do is he had to take over a group of
American cadets who were going to be
trained in Italy the United States was
going to ship over they weren't going to
ship the airplanes they were going to
ship the material and the Italians would
build the airplanes and the Italians
would trade them train them and feed
them and house them well he first
started showing his colors when he went
down to get the Cunard Line to get
tickets for these for his cadets his
boys that were supposed to travel
third-class he said no no no my boys
travel first-class and he put out
something like thirty six thousand
dollars and the government had a fit but
then they realized you don't mess around
with a congressman when they got over to
Italy and they set up the camp he
immediately took over he was a takeover
guy and I'm not only to take charge and
take over and after one meal he said
what is this garbage you're feeding
these people he said you're feeding I'm
a ball of spaghetti and a glass of a cup
of oil and a hunk of bread he said no no
no no he called in the caterer he said I
want the caterer who caters all the
world family events bring him in the
caterer came in and he sat down he said
now we're gonna work out 21 menus which
we're gonna rotate week after week and
the breakfast is gonna be steak and eggs
and bacon or ham and toast and blah blah
blah and a three-course the lunch and a
four-course meal and his boys ate well
then the time comes when the caterer
presents the bill look why I said oh go
go give it to the Italian government and
the Italian government had a fit and
they complained to the commanding
general wasn't purging Pershing was
still in the state's training the troops
and the commanding generals thought it
was the funniest thing he ever heard and
they arranged that the Italians had to
pay for the pay the caterers meals so
his boys ate well he was also on the
joint allied Commission he was a spy I
don't want to go into the details now
but
arrays a to get into Spain and covertly
arrange for a shipment of vital goods
into into the war zone and he was a
great propagandist he would travel up
and down the coast of Italy telling the
people hold on if this was after
Caporetto when the 300,000 that died an
army collapsed I mean you know the
French aren't the only ones whose arm is
collapsed in a hurry the italians this
was a big one and he went up and down he
said the attack the Americans are coming
hold in and but he liked to lecture and
cut down on overeating we don't want you
to get too fat he always he always had
and they loved it because he was
speaking to them in their language when
he came back a hero and he was he was
promoted to major he loved to be called
major he didn't like to be called mayor
he liked to be called major referred to
as the major and he came back and he
returned to Congress first thing he did
is got the money doctorate and they said
whatever he is then after his second
term he became the head of the Board of
Aldermen
Al Smith who was the head of the Board
of Aldermen had going on to run for had
become governor and the people the
politician said come back and be the
head of the Board of Aldermen and we'll
support you for mayor well that was a
big mistake first of all he had no power
as the Board of Aldermen and when he ran
against Jimmy Walker it was it was
impossible because the zeitgeist at the
time was everybody's having a good time
and yeah Jimmy is our boy he spent his
whole term in the COS in the casino in
Central Park I mean he was worth Sports
mayor he was a crook as a matter of fact
judge Seabury who was called in to clean
up the city and the corruption when
after Walker Walker had a really into
exile anyway look what he got re-elected
to Congress for five more five more
terms but he's not from Greenwich
Village
he went up to
East Harlem the the 88 their 20th
congressional district because his buddy
up there congressman Siegel who had
represented him on the floor of Congress
when he was in the in the service had
been given a judgeship and this way this
was an ideal district for him because
who was made up of Italian Jew it's
Italian Americans Jewish Americans
German Americans Croatian Americans
Hungarian Americans and he spoke to them
in their own language he was he was his
self trained linguist when he became a
lame-duck congressman in 1932 Roosevelt
had been elected president but the 20th
amendment which calls for the
inauguration of the president in January
had not gone into effect that it would
go into effect in Roosevelt's next like
inauguration so there was that period up
until March where Congress was still
controlled by the Republicans and still
controlled by hurt you know Herbert
Hoover and they could pass any kind of
legislation that Rosa would have been
locked into and Roosevelt said to his
brain trust burly find me somebody that
can you know do something there
he said we got to have LaGuardia because
LaGuardia they're afraid of him in
Congress I'll give an example what he
used to do he liked to do dog and pony
shows when he went after the big meat
packers he's saying these people they're
Paley they Ranchers nothing and they're
charging the poor people high prices and
they're pocketing and he said Whitman I
had I have something here and he pulled
out something up this big he said you
see this this is a roast for a family of
four and then he said Wayman I have
something else here and they pulled out
something and then and this is a lamb
chop that they're supposed to feed on
his dog and pony show against
prohibition what he did something very
clever
he took legal the near beer which was a
legal beer and malt which he would buy
it in a drugstore and he mixed it he
said here you have beer you want pill
stir Dettol
salt he was great for these dog and pony
shows and if anything and anybody was
against him he didn't care where he was
he wouldn't he wouldn't he would open
his mouth when he was trying a law case
and if and if the opposition objected
too much he would turn to him and say
hey who do you represent slep or Ghana
for schmuck get out of here go back to
school your honor get him out of here
and after the his honor had gotten the
courtroom calmed down he said perhaps
the Consul would like to rephrase he
said yeah Howie phrasing he would look
at the juries a toy and then he would
yank on his pants well he wasn't using
that to gird for battle he was always
ready to be girded for battle he was
doing it because they were falling to
the floor his beloved wife Marie his
second wife who has started his his
first wife died very young very
tragically and Marie his second wife had
been his first Louis legal secretary she
was like the wife and waiting and she
turned out to be terrific gal whenever
he left the house she made sure that he
was perfectly turned out that I was not
at right that handkerchief everything
was fine he was he was a haberdashers
dream in 15 minutes he would be an apt
haberdashers worst nightmare he his his
a during the army was the famous
violinist Albert Spalding who said this
man is always looks like he's like an
unmade bed he built the New York City by
create by bringing the city together and
connecting it with these great bridges
and tunnels and all of that now true
Robert Moses was the genius behind the
infrastructure but without LaGuardia
Robert Moses could not have built a toy
house because Roosevelt hated Moses with
a passion not to be believed
so the Moses needed LaGuardia to get the
money
LaGuardia had no money problem getting
money out of Washington because
Roosevelt first of all appreciated
that he had held the line for him till
he got in and he felt that he owed him a
debt of honor and Roosevelt wasn't a
great one for paying debts of honor but
this one he did because New York City
was also a showcase for his New Deal he
got more money out of the federal
government than any state so he was in
effect New York City was in effect the
49th state but actually it was the first
state because he got more than any other
he not only built up to sit but he
wanted the people to have everything
that he that the aristocrat said for
instance he said why can't put why must
the poor people be denying opera and
theater and so on and so for it can't
have that he was the one that started
the City Center for the Performing Arts
he said but I don't want ballet he said
I don't like to see men flying through
the air with the crutches I know but
they they had the ballet anyway and but
he was and he was in the middle of
everything
when Gertrude Lawrence the the famous
English comedian and actress opened in
the first play he ran her lines for her
that's as you know when the actress just
wants the cues but while running the
lines for her he started redirecting her
and of course she she took it good
unless she's just ignored if she said
that you know she wasn't her own
director he was a great music lover of
classical music
Enrico Caruso was a great buddy of his a
mad fact they were married on the same
day in st. Patrick's Cathedral
he liked to conduct an orchestra he left
to go to rehearsals whenever he had time
and once he was conducting a symphony
orchestra paired to conduct a symphony
orchestra and the people said are there
any special arrangements you want made
he said no just treat me the way you
treat us any he could have a number of
he had a number of sticks that bordered
on cruelty but there were various kinds
of cruelty one was the public
humiliation cruelty but he didn't really
mean it but when he meant that
the time as when he told the secretary
who had goofed up in front of a group of
people he said if you were any Dumber
I'd make you a city commissioner then
there was the time when one of his
commissioners made a gaffe and it wasn't
a big deal but he just had to get the
needle in and they sent a clipping of
the newspaper of a Japanese government
minister who had committed harakiri for
some atone for humiliation and rose and
and he wrote across the bottom now this
is what I call style my favorite of
these incidents of his cruelty is when
he stormed into civic city hall one
Monday morning he never entered a room
he stormed he said get me Commissioner
so-and-so on the phone because he had
heard there was a problem in the
department and then he ran into his
office and he slammed the door well the
secretary got nervous she tracked down
the Commissioner he was still at his
home up in this his weekend home in the
Catskills jump to his car he came
tearing down the Taconic Parkway ran
across it he got down a city hall that
jumped out of the car in the parking lot
he left the ED the key in the ignition
the engine running and he ran into City
Hall ran down to the basement that's
where laguardia's office was and he
rapped on the door and LaGuardia was was
entertaining as somebody to come in and
the Commissioner walks in and LaGuardia
looks up and said like yeah what do you
want
and the commission said you sent for me
he said Oh how's everything your
department I said fine
look why I said okay you can go that's
not the point he turns to the visitors
and oops wrong Commissioner he was when
he when the World's Fair was being built
he personally was out there he moved the
entire city government out to Flushing
Meadow and he was around there he really
was making an issue himself but the
point is he was a hands-on mayor he
embarrassed the State Department which
was kind of anti-semitic we were not at
war with Germany yet and he said I
decided that in addition to the
buildings announced we're gonna have a
chamber of horrors and it's going to be
devoted to pictures of Hitler and
Goering and all of these people and the
State Department had a hemorrhage and
they appealed to Roosevelt and Roosevelt
was amused he said I don't want to you
know don't come to me with this because
Roosevelt hated these people anyway
needless to say the Germans hated him
and Chris he hated them he had built the
city up in those first two
administrations he created the airport
now people think that they just named
the airport for him he created the
airport LaGuardia Airport the way he
came to create it he was flying from
Chicago to New York on a trip and the
ticket said Chicago to New York and the
flight terminated in Newark because
there was no airport he said what's tip
this is not New York well this is as far
as it he said my ticket says Chicago to
New York and I'm flying from Chicago to
New York and they had to send an army
plane out from Floyd Bennett Field to
bring him into New York and of course he
was a great believer in airpower he was
one of the earliest backers of general
Billy Mitchell he said you don't have to
sink an airport an aircraft carrier to
prove that you know the power of
aircraft he said take my word for it but
they had it they had to do it anyway
he not only built the LaGuardia Airport
but incidentally he built Idlewild
Airport which we now know as JFK he I
wish that he had not run for a third
term
he was the first mayor to be elected for
a third term because by then he had
become very testy he had become very
easily irritated and he was very
aggravated because he had expected to be
made a brigadier general in the army and
he was not Roosevelt didn't know what to
do it in Roosevelt would have given him
some roosevelt liked him although
roosevelt admitted to burly at time he
said that time this guy could drive me
crazy but I love him and so Roosevelt
consulted his commanders general marshal
General Eisenhower what can we do and
they said we don't want him because he's
you can't control him there's absolutely
no control there and he was very very
disappointing it was very bitter he
agreed to accept the role of an in
charge of defense the popular what we
call the this new office that they
created yeah right and he had a better I
bet but he made a mess of thing and
first of all he was running around
insisting that everybody in the United
States be outfitted for a gas-mask well
I mean there was no chances of up German
airplanes coming over and gas in the
country but he went around he made sure
that hospitals were well-stocked and
everything but he was he was he was a
burnt-out case he really was a
burned-out case and as I say the
everything that he had accomplished for
New York City he accomplished in his
first two terms and it was more than any
other mayor accomplished in New York
City and more than any mayor
accomplished for any city and the fact
that the mayor's the national mayor's
appreciated what he did for them is they
can kept electing him President of the
Council of Mayors which was which was a
new organization because he stuck up for
them in Washington
are there any questions incidentally
because I was told to answer their any
questions no all right then I'll keep -
how much time do I have left how much 15
minute okay well I'll find something to
say for 15 minutes he was a great man I
I didn't prepare any speech but I
prepared a couple of quotes which I
think define the main one is the more I
get to know about lawyers and their
ethics the LIA though that's respect I
have for them
he went into law dedicated to the idea
of helping the poor people when he saw
that the lawyers were working on behalf
of the oligarchs that's when he got
really got to hate them
when he went to Congress and he was
voting and he told his constituency
don't blame me if I if you don't like
the way I vote because I'm gonna vote
according to my conscience and he did
say he was not a Republican he was not a
Democrat he was a progressive
and as a mayor he was a fusionist he
also took the attitude I would rather be
right than regular especially when he
was in Congress and his own people were
saying you're not doing the right thing
you're not voting right the way should
be he said I'm voting the what the way I
see it is right another way I would not
be I don't want to be a regular
politician I want to be a right
politician dude yeah that's yeah
LaGuardia was fully aware of the
contempt with which Moses Oh was he
heard as it were how did that play out
how are they separated where safaris
like it was like a marriage made in hell
where they couldn't get along with each
other and they couldn't get along
without each other
Moses was a genius when it came to
constructing bridges parks recreational
areas buildings so on and so forth but
he needed money for that and he would
not get a penny from Washington so he
needed LaGuardia to get the money for
him and LaGuardia needed his genius
although Moses was a one-man Horror Show
he was such a nasty guy that instead of
going to Commissioner meetings he was
sent a potted plant and ministers were
he he showed his contempt but he did a
marvelous job I don't want to get down
that Moses Road because Robert Caro did
it so beautifully but I will mention
that in building up the city
he helped destroy the city because he
moved all of these broke up these
neighborhoods and move the people out to
the suburbs in order to make room for
the bridges and then the more bridges
and tunnels you had the more traffic you
had and that's what we have is a
nightmare one thing I forgot to mention
which i think is very important is
LaGuardia and the the blacks there were
Vic called Negros attack he was the
first one to name a Negro commissioner
in the history of this city and he
turned out to be one of the best
commissioners he was the first one to
name a Negro judge she turned out to be
one of the best it was also the first
one to name a woman judge she turned out
to be one of the best when the Harlem
riots broke out during the war he went
right up there and established a command
post and he got even those black leaders
who didn't like him like the Powell jr.
and he got them plus those who did
respect him like Walter White the head
of NAACP and they got on a on a truck
and they went around and and they they
calm the city debt he kept the city from
blowing up when it came to selecting
commissioners and his staffing he wanted
only the best on his first day as mayor
he went around to swear in the
commissioners in their office it wasn't
going to be one of these mayor's things
and he laid down the law he said you're
gonna do it hands on or you're out of
here
none of this business is sitting on your
rumps in your office you're gonna be out
in the field he had to make one he had
to pay one pull in a political debt as a
commissioner this was the police
commissioner because general Ryan had
was the Republican that the Republican
fusionist wanted to run for mayor and a
judge a judge Seabury said no will take
LaGuardia so Ryan agreed to step aside
and he was you know LaGuardia said I had
to take him but I don't have to live
with him what he did is he got a hold of
the top he said who's the time
policemen in this city well it was the
Chief of Detectives he said send him to
me he said can we work together he said
yes sir he said okay I'll work with you
I don't like y'all throw you out well
they work together beautifully so much
so that Ryan was so humiliated he
retired from office and LaGuardia moved
this man into office and this was Louis
J Valentine who is going down as the
city's greatest police commissioner
today yeah many of our more recent
mayors and many mayor's face crises
within their administration's and you
just talked about one particular thing
number one what was laguardia's greatest
crisis and two how do you think he would
have been as mayor had 9/11 been on his
well had he been mayor at the time of
9/11 because I think this I think this
is important he was not only a hands-on
mayor but he was a body in mayor for
instance once he was sitting in enjoying
a concert show in Radio City and he
heard a fire engine and he jumped up and
he ran out and he broke about 15 pairs
of ankles and he ran to the fire which
was a few blocks away and he got in
there and the fire was put out after
about an hour and meanwhile where's
LaGuardia he still had the mayor's still
in the building well he finally came out
about 15 minutes that he said I just
wanted to make sure that everybody was
out and I just want to make sure
everything is under control as far as
the 911 now this is no disrespect to
Giuliani because Giuliani his
performance at 9/11 was was brilliant it
was great I mean I really believed that
they would have had to bodily hold
LaGuardia back from going into the
building
because that's the way he was he would
have been right there and they would
have had to physically restrain him from
going not that I expected the mayor
should go into the building but that's
the way he was his greatest crisis
probably his greatest crisis was the was
the the rut the Harlem riots
and he handled them beautifully started
on a Saturday and by Tuesday was over
because he went up there and he and he
got everybody the important people
regardless of what they thought of him
to ride around on flatbed trucks and and
calm the people down and they did calm
the people down there was very little
looting and that was probably his
greatest crisis it's a beaut he referred
to many things but one is when that
Commissioner came in when he called the
home commissioner and it was not all
that cool but it was I I think it was
kind of funny I think it was difficult
yeah how formative that was very
formative the happiest years of his life
were spent on the western frontier his
father was a an army band master
that's why LaGuardia always wore that 10
gallon sombrero black ten gallon Stetson
rather and he very well from war a
string tie and to memorialize his years
on the west he absolutely loved them and
he began to show what he was when he was
out there he was he's very short you
know and if he wanted to be heard he
would be heard he would drag a table out
and a chair and step from the chair to
the table
he said now hear this I have something
to tell you people he was all of nine
years old he oh he always had something
to say to somebody he was a very many
chiyan character it was either good or
bad
there was no charity row there no no in
between
yeah and I don't claim Pat did not get
along how come and also what made the
that that Police Commissioner so so good
one of the city's best commissioners
what made the West what was his name
Valentino you said the Valentine the the
police because he kept the lid on on the
city he was he broke them there first of
all they broke the back of the of the
the slot machine which was which was a
big racket and this was another one of
his famous dog and pony shows after they
ran all of the slot machine Kings out
including Frank Costello and you know
who he was
big mafia man he chartered a rare big
raft the big scow and he loaded about
20,000 machines on and he invited the
and he whacked the hell out of them what
I would have had it and then dump them
all overboard he hated he hated he hated
criminals he hated the whole bit I have
a something that if I have about a
minute left I just something I'd like to
read I was asked to do a piece for
American History Magazine on LaGuardia
and I had to do a summation so I'm gonna
read you something that I wrote because
I feel that it is so typify Denny said
in pursuing the betterment of the masses
which he referred to as the people he
went after what he dismissed
contemptuously as the interests the
oligarchic bankers industrialists and
corporate executives like a bull in a
china shop who not only makes a dreadful
mess of the priceless china but also of
the furniture and display cases and then
caps the happening with the metaphorical
exclamation point by reducing the shop
itself to rubble will New York will the
nation ever again see the likes of such
a political force we cannot know of
course for sure at this point all we can
cry do is cry out agonizingly Fiorello
where are you now that we need you
ten minutes more I have ten minutes more
three questions
yeah that's questionnaire he asked why
fear of the water didn't get along with
Adam Clayton Powell asked why didn't
that affect I'll get along a freeway
LaGuardia yeah right sorry
that's way was I mean Adam Clayton
Powell want to be the bride at every
wedding of the corpse at every funeral
its but not only as regarded his own
people but but the city itself he have
to realize that this man was a very
powerful man his father was the heed
from very prominent family his father
was the was the pastor of the Abyssinian
Baptist Church which is the largest
wealthiest afro-american Church in the
in the world probably Powell proved what
he what he the you know the caliber of
man he was because look at the way he
ended his career he was he was to use
one of the laguardia's favorite words a
ganas
but but LaGuardia ignored him ignored
him and to Clayton Powell's and to
Powell's great credit when the riots
broke out he joined with Walter White
who had a great respect for LaGuardia
and a Phillip Randolph and all of these
other great black leaders and he joined
with them and he did give little
guardias do and taught me about giving
LaGuardia his do as much as Robert Moses
despised LaGuardia and LaGuardia used to
give him a needle because of Moses
couldn't have his way he would say I
quit well it got to the point where
LaGuardia had a pad printed up of forms
the I quit for him with the date and you
know sign it and every time Moses came
in he would shove the pad at him he said
okay fill it out and and and this this
this irritated him more than ever and if
he sent a potted plant to the
commissioners meeting
LaGuardia would stick him a message on
the potted plant we didn't miss you and
send the plant back
in other words he could not get the best
of LaGuardia and he realized he need him
and I must say to to his credit when
LaGuardia died he eulogized him he
realized that yeah yeah we didn't get
along but he was a great man he died in
48 yeah after the after he left office
he took over as head of Unruh and then
that last about a year that he came back
then he started making money doing
broadcast radio broadcast he patently
controlled WNYC and he would give them
war news and then he would say now
ladies asparagus is too expensive this
week don't buy it and the people who the
grocer's were throwing the asparagus
away or else this week is a good week to
buy quality flour and ladies I want you
to make sure it was very bad weather out
today you'll be sure to wear your
galoshes and carry your umbrella and he
always had and then when he read the
comics to the children he would have a
little homily I liked when the newspaper
strike of 1945 he said no the kid he
loved children he adored children he
referred to them as the kiddies but he
addressed him as boys and girls he said
no the kiddies have got to have Dick
Tracy they've got to have their comics
so he read the Dick Tracy thing and he
dramatized it
he said now first of all boys and girls
do you all have your Dick Tracy
communication wristwatch on of course we
all did I mean was a 5 cent piece of
junk that came in a crackerjack box and
we would all sit by the radio and he big
consoles would be Ford the portable say
well now last week you'll remember so
and so and so so now let's see we're
picked up this week Oh dick and Tess his
girlfriend I think they're gonna get
married
you heard it here boys and girls they're
walking oh wait a minute huh uh-oh we
got trouble flat
head is following him now quick get on
your freight wristbands and warn them so
we all got on my wristband and dead for
chocolate we're talking to our wrists
like a bunch of idiots and then he said
it looks bad and then there's silence
and our heart is in our throat and then
we hear a building just fell on flat
head their contest's are gonna be all
right and then would come the homily now
boys and girls remember if anybody like
flat head is ever following you you
unwrite to the nearest policeman you say
mr. policeman flat head is after me and
the policeman will take care of you
there was always a homily yeah I read
somewhere that some laguardia supposedly
a comment from the water so fright after
he retired his last term I might have to
finish he was asked about Robert Moses
and he said he kind of he felt kind of
worried because he felt that although he
could never really control him he was
only one who could restrain him as much
as he did
what he needed him he needed him they
needed each other he needed Moses
because although Moses was a one-man
horror show he was a genius when it came
to building bridges parks schools
housing so on son
let me say something about the housing
when the Prudential Insurance Company
went to build what we know no
established in town they said that
blacks will not be allowed in and the
global LaGuardia called them in he said
look you people write a hundred thousand
policies in Harlem alone and you think
and you're gonna take the money and
they're not going to get in you're not
getting that money you're not gonna be
building that I know then when he would
find another well the Prudential had him
back down then he went after the
telephone company he went after Gimbels
he went after Macy's he went after he
said you people are taking the money of
these of these black people but you're
treating them like second inferior
citizens we have that it was the
beginning of the black revolution if you
will to use
I mean the other way he was that concern
he was a very socially committed person
he was very socially committed that's it
okay we filled up the time Thank You
Alan broadsky thank you all for joining
us we have copies of the great mayor to
the rear of the event space we invite
you to come up now and have your book
signed thank you and good afternoon
Alan Bronski is author of the great
mayor it's published by st. Martin's
Press on the web at st. Martin's dot-com